it's an image that will go down in
history for the first time since
fighting engine in 1953 and North Korean
leader in this case the ruthless
dictator Kim jong-un has set foot in
South Korea to declare his supposed
intentions for peace and
denuclearization now the questions are
is this really a moment of peace what
can we expect and why does everything
seem to suddenly be going so smoothly I
mean is North Korea really willing to
give up that nuclear bomb well the view
of these are some of the questions that
I'm sure you are all thinking well let's
have a look at it shall we humming while
walking and even holding hands toasting
and dying together this is how we were
able to witness the North and South
Korean leaders last Friday on April the
27th 2018
we're talking about the latest inter
career summit in which both countries
committed to seeking a definitive peace
agreements technically both Koreas are
still at war to rebuild their relations
and pursue the denuclearization of the
Korean Peninsula the summit took place
in the Demilitarized Zone in the town of
pan Minh John in the exact place where
the Korean War armistice was signed
[Music]
both the North Korean leader Kim jong-un
and South Korean president moon jaein
displayed a level of complicity that
would have been very hard to imagine
only a few months ago
[Music]
and the pictures from that day they are
going to go down in history and I'm
really not exaggerating here the scenes
that we saw of walks handshakes and
whispers between the two leaders
wouldn't have been out of place in a
romance movie do you remember the
honeymoon I promised you well we're
going to have it and you know what in a
way that was precisely what was
happening it was a political courtship
between two leaders who really couldn't
be more different on the one hand you
have the South Korean president moon
jae-in a lawyer who specialized in human
rights a man of humble origins whose
parents managed to flee from North Korea
and he was an activist for democracy
during his youth and on the other hand
we have kim jeong-hoon one of the worst
tyrants on the planet he's the
omnipotent leader of one of the most
terrible countries that anyone could
possibly imagine because my friends
despite four summits images in which Kim
jong-un almost looked like a Care Bear
let's not forget who he really is let's
not forget that the North Korean leader
heads a regime of terror in which human
rights violations are part of the
state's routine functions we've almost
forgotten the allegations that he had
his half-brother killed with a chemical
weapon just last year and then he had
his uncle ripped apart with
anti-aircraft guns Gary Samore Obama's
White House coordinator for arms control
and weapons of mass destruction in spite
of that and thanks to the images we saw
and the declaration both governments
agreed on most of the press described
this meeting as a historic day the day
when once and for all
peace triumphed
[Music]
all right so now the question really has
to be well how true is all of this are
things really going that well in other
words are we facing a sincere exercise
in diplomacy or simply a big marketing
scam has pyongyang roadmap actually
changed my dialogue is certainly better
than a march to war that said we all
need to keep our expectations in check
Wendy R Sherman US Undersecretary of
State for political affairs from 2011 to
2015 and North Korea policy coordinator
in the Clinton administration will
explore this but first here's a question
that I'm sure many of us have asked how
the hell did we go in just a few months
from hearing the drums of war
every single pixel
this actual cordial and harmonious
meeting
[Music]
well we can come up with three different
explanations that still complements the
North Korean regimes new behavior which
in a very short time when srem
threatening the United States to
suspending its nuclear and missile tests
North Korea threatens to turn us into
sea of flames North Korea says it will
suspend nuclear and missile tests so
let's take a look at the possible
reasons for this change and let me tell
you things are not as simple as they
seem
[Music]
John yang we have a problem
the first possible explanation according
to several analysts from the United
States and South Korea and two studies
by Chinese researchers the punggye-ri
nuclear test center located in the heart
of a 2,200 meter high mountain known as
mount man tap codes have collapsed after
the last atomic test in which a
thermonuclear bomb of 250 kilo tons was
detonated by North Korea in this area on
September the 3rd 2017
the explosion was so strong that it
caused a 6.3 magnitude earthquake well
the collapse seems to have been
confirmed and it isn't clear whether the
center is operational ask based on the
severity of the initial blast the
post-tests tremors and the extent of
observable surface disturbances we have
to assume that there must have been
substantial damage to the existing
tunnel network under mount Mann tap
Frank V papian and Jack Lew if it isn't
operational or if it's too badly damaged
it could take some time for the regime
to rebuild it enough to be able to hold
new tests in a safe manner this could
have definitely been effective they
could have altered the deadlines but it
doesn't seem like this could have been
the main cause for the change of
discourse
it's the economy stupid another
hypothesis has to do with the effects of
international sanctions on the North
Korean economy as you all know North
Korea is a very very poor country you
see for years a large part of the
international community has imposed
sanctions on North Korea but these have
generally not affected the country's
main partners China Russia and Vietnam
however all of this began to change with
the sanctions that the United Nations
began imposing on North Korea in 2017 in
response to its continued nuclear tests
for the first time these sanctions were
greatly fulfilled by China and that
Divya was a very hard blow to North
Korea the vast majority of North Korean
trade happens with China
Nantz if that's cut well young yang has
a very serious problem a problem that
multiplied when in September after the
last thermonuclear test the United
Nations Security Council and all of
North Korea's key exports including coal
iron and textiles this resolution is the
single largest economic sanctions
package ever leveled against the North
Korean regime the price the North Korean
leadership will pay for its continued
nuclear and missile development will be
the loss of one-third of its exports and
hard currency and not only that in
December the same body agreed to limit
their refined oil imports to half a
million barrels per year a 90% reduction
compared to the amount of refined oil
North Korea had purchased over the
previous year and what was the result of
all of this well several factories had
to close due to a lack of raw materials
and the army due to a lack of gasoline
had to resort to coal engines and even
ox carts and although it may surprise
you this situation doesn't only
accentuate North Korea's weaknesses but
it also is a hard blow to Kim Jong Un's
government's making economic development
a big priority and of course these
sanctions are also affecting the level
of life the elites and the incipient
middle class enjoy
well hold on a moment certain emerging
middle class in North Korea well yeah
you heard it right in fact here's a
question for you do you think that a
capitalist market can be developing
within present-day North Korea well stay
tuned for an upcoming video that we have
on that but even though all of this is
important and to certainly influence the
situation it doesn't sound like
something that could put the regime at
risk at least not for the moment if you
think the North Koreans would revolt or
the regime would collapse because of
sanctions you don't know anything about
the North Koreans these are people who
survive the famine by eating weeds kang
Meighan a North Korean defector who
works for South Korea's Central Bank of
Korea so then why is Pyongyang changed
its discourse so much or has it really
just actually changed
[Music]
North Korea is a nuclear power that is
simply a fact according to American
intelligence this country currently
could have between 20 and 60 warheads
that are ready for use in other words
Pyongyang has already achieved its great
goal it has its insurance it has the
best deterrence that has ever been built
[Music]
now it is true that in the last April
27th into Korea some is North Korea
promised to denuclearize the peninsula
but hold on a moment because that
doesn't mean it's willing to give up its
nuclear weapons first because North
Korea has already promised many things
that they didn't do for example the
negotiations and agreements of 1991 1994
2000 2007 2012 North Korean promises not
exactly something new and so far they
have always been rather flimsy you see a
1994 Kim Jong Un's father Kim jong-il
even went so far as to start dismantling
the nuclear program allowing
international inspectors to visit the
country to verify the process this was
all in exchange for some generous help
in the United States however years later
the world found out that it had been a
scam the program had continued
developing clandestinely in 2000 South
Korean president Kim dae-jung announced
that a new day would come after
returning from his visit with Kim
jong-il in Pyongyang in 2007 South
Korean President Roh moo-hyun stated
during his visit to North Korea that Kim
jong-il has shown a will to restore
peace
[Music]
and the second reason we can't assume
North Korea will give up its nuclear
weapons is that we may not be on the
same page about what constitutes
denuclearization allow me to explain for
Pyongyang this term has got a lot to do
not only with its nuclear weapons but
also with the US military's capabilities
in the peninsula and in the region and
in any case the truth is that it seems
very difficult for Kim Jong hoon to be
willing to part with his best life
insurance we must remember North Korea
is still North Korea Kim is still the
same person he was when he purged
potential rivals imprisoned thousands of
his people and had his relatives killed
this was a hopeful moment but extreme
caution is well warranted Abraham
Denmark director of the Asian program at
the Woodrow Wilson Center and former us
Assistant Secretary of Defense for East
Asia in fact this is something that
intercepted North Korean communications
have definitely shown everything seems
to be part of some kind of road map
first ensure the survival of the regime
something he has achieved with his
nuclear arsenal and second negotiate
with the international community to end
the sanctions and to launch a reform
program that can attract investment from
China and South Korea
[Music]
that means although far from how things
might seem at first young yang could
simply be following a well outlined plan
was the inter-korean summit a big
marketing exercise then this in a way
explains why South Koreans are so
skeptical of the North's promises I mean
just check out this survey
[Music]
but now well it's your turn do you think
North Korea will actually give up its
nuclear program leave your comments
below and also in this survey and I
really hope you enjoyed their video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday also don't
forget to check out our friends at the
reconsider Media podcast they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not
mine and as always thank you for
watching
[Music]